[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily execution
scheduled for federal inmates during the
coven 19 pandemic
celebrity calls for clemency concerns
and controversies
i am really um upset
uh appalled disgusted by
the rush to execute people a mother's
emotional plea
after her daughter's murder she wants
accountability for her eight-year-old's
death
kids are dying because you guys are not
doing
your jobs plus a mother's dismember
remains found on the property of her
estranged husband's family
why her accused killers want evidence
tossed out of a case
you can't break the law to enforce the
law
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast welcome everyone to
law and crime daily i'm brian buckmart
along with terry austin
two federal inmates are scheduled to be
executed despite
covet 19 concerns law and crimes anjanet
levy is here to explain
brandon bernard and alfred bourgeois are
scheduled to be executed
this week bernard's lawyers have been
trying to halt his
execution the seventh circuit court of
appeals in chicago has denied a request
for an appeal
and an emergency stay this comes as it
came out that members of the prisons
execution team in terre haute indiana
have tested positive for covet 19
and that's leading to more calls to
delays these executions
reality tv star kim kardashian west is
backing the effort to save bernard's
life
kardashian west sent out a new series of
tweets asking her followers to tweet
president trump
and call the white house to persuade him
to commute the sentence
only president trump or a federal judge
can stop the execution
since the murders of todd and stacy
bagley were federal crimes
because they happened at fort hood the
bagleys begged for their lives as they
were robbed
shot in the head and set on fire in one
tweet
kardashian west said bernard should get
life without parole because he was only
18 at the time
he wasn't the shooter and a former
prosecutor on the case
and some jurors also support life
without parole for him
former u.s attorney for the southern
district of ohio ben glassman
handled death eligible cases he believes
the executions should stop
until kovitz subsides my reaction to
that is that the bureau of prisons
has had a horrible time dealing with
covet as you could imagine
and so it it just
i don't understand from a criminal
justice perspective
why you would be engaging in
activities that are not time sensitive
that
further endanger uh bop staff
or other inmates with the spread of
covid if you didn't have to
so i i guess i'm just i don't understand
why
it's so important from the department's
perspective to move forward on these
executions at this time
the associated press has reported that
five of the execution team members that
contracted covet and have recovered
will carry out this week's executions
now we spoke with david singleton he is
the head of the ohio justice and policy
center
he doesn't believe these executions
should be happening at all but in light
of covid
he believes they should be stopped i was
not surprised
to hear that federal executions would
begin again under the trump
administration
i was disappointed not surprised but the
rush
the speed by which they are working to
execute people is is breathtaking
and that should not be happening i mean
people are getting execution dates
uh thrown at them really quickly lawyers
aren't having enough time
to seek clemency and pursue last uh
last-ditch efforts uh to save to save
their their clients lives
and so there's just no need for this
now as i mentioned a former federal
prosecutor who worked to
uphold brandon bernard's death sentence
now says he should get
life without parole
young men are different they act
impulsively
they do not consider consequences they
are
easily led by a leader
and that's what happened to mr bernard
if you look at the facts of this case
he did not play near the role that the
government
said he did or pushed that he did he
received the death penalty largely
because
he was an adult
my justice department lawyer said
earlier this week that it's really
impossible to know how those
execution team members contracted
coveted 19 he said they could have
picked it up
in many different places now earlier
today i reached out to both the
department of justice and the bureau of
prisons so far
my emails have not been returned
president-elect joe biden meanwhile has
said he will work to
end federal executions brian we'll send
it back to you
thanks anjanet the hope is that we can
maybe press pause there and
get some more information on that case
before the death penalty is executed
joining me now is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi along with terry
austin
terry let's start with you it's down to
the wire for bernard's execution
what arguments if any do you think could
save his life at this point
you know it really is down to the wire
and i think the best arguments have
already been made the fact that he was
18 when this crime occurred and also the
fact that he did not actively
participate
in the actual murder that should have
been enough to spare his life
if in fact both victims died from the
gunshot wounds to the head and
no one died from the smoke then i think
life
in prison would have been justified
now gene they are speeding towards an
execution as they said there
on the earlier interviews with anjanet
and the country's also
turning from the death penalty just in
general do you think it's time to
revisit how clemency
is granted to allow a clearer path to
receiving it
absolutely i think when we get a new
regime on january 20th
at the justice department we should
revamp the whole pardon process
and also the commutation process because
right now the perception
among the public is that it's very
political and it's not what you did
it's who you know and especially with
the death penalty
uh individuals are getting commuted uh
for lesser crimes but someone like mr
bernard
who is now being asked who is being
supported by
five jurors two former prosecutors
he wasn't a shooter he was 18 at the
time
i think in his case it it
screams for a commutation
exactly and hopefully those screams are
heard because again like you said
it's down to the wire still ahead on law
and crime daily
we break down the court hearing of a
deadly custody dispute
plus why a mother is calling for
accountability in her daughter's death
after the break
[Music]
an illinois mother is suing the state
and the department of children and
family services
after her daughter died of abuse
eight-year-old rico roundtree was killed
in 2018
from being kicked in the stomach so hard
it tore her intestines
dcfs placed rika with her biological
father
allegedly ignoring reports of abuse from
the girl and her school
his girlfriend cynthia clay was
convicted of murdering rika
and is serving a life sentence her
father richard rountree
is serving eight years for child
endangerment disturbing videos capture
the abuse
that her mother says happened for years
even dcfs wasn't even listening to the
school i mean my daughter's got black
eyes broken teeth she's got her hair
shaped she's sitting in class you know
limped over
like in the teacher's words an 80 year
old woman
um but just not being able to move you
know the psychological
you know that she went through talking
to dcfs like these are supposed to be
people
that are supposed to protect our
children and there's no way
that you can look at my child
before and after and tell me that
everything in between was okay
rika's mother says the lawsuit isn't
about damages it's about accountability
rico is going to leave a legacy her
death was not for nothing
every mix she took every piece of pain
she endured
every second of her miserable last years
are gonna be for something i need
changes i need policy changes i need
people that are in these positions to do
their jobs act like they care
and then i'm left in this position
knowing that for two and a half years
i find new things that took me down
there lost my sanity
trying to get somebody to listen to me
to save my daughter's life
only to have her die weeks after dcfc
there's no way this should have ever
happened
rika's mother's attorneys announced
state and federal lawsuits
rica had dozens of scars on her back and
torso
scars and abrasions to her face and neck
scarring on her upper left thigh from
cigarette burns
and bruises literally all over her body
there is a willful and wanton disregard
for the well-being of innocent children
no lawsuit would ever bring rica back
to her mother and her brothers and her
family
but at some point a lie must be drawn
somewhere telling the state of illinois
that enough is enough
back with me our attorneys gene rossi
and terry austin
gene you heard benjamin crump lists the
number of injuries there
but the dcf says the claims were of
abuse at least were unfounded at the
time
how can an agency have failed so badly
to identify these injuries
it's a combination of two things in my
view
lack of training adequate training and
also
callous disregard when an agency drops
the ball
and allows this horrible murder if you
if you will happen to this beautiful
young girl
it's a failure of the agency in terms of
training people
on how to detect uh incidences of child
abuse
and there was a level of of um
uncaring if you will on a part of the
agency
and just because the agency's mission is
to protect the kids
doesn't mean that everybody in that
agency has the skill set
or the passion for their job i worked in
a federal government for a long time
there are many people who are great in
doing their job
and then there are some who shouldn't be
working for the government
now terry i've seen cases like this i
mean we both have seen cases like this i
think it's going to be a successful one
but tell us how this lawsuit is going to
protect future children
well let's hope that as gene said it's
going to protect future children because
there will be a change in policy we know
that there will be hopefully
some financial reward as far as you know
rika is concerned and her family is
concerned
but i am hoping that we see changes and
that we see
training and that we see policy changes
so that they follow up
on reports of abuse they look more
closely when they see children who
actually have injuries that they
go back they report that they talk to
the doctors and they do something about
it so i think gene hit it on the head
we have to make sure that they're
trained
and here's the hope that rika's legacy
can be that for illinois to change the
policies to help other children
still ahead on law and crime daily a
father and son accused of murder
the legal battle their defense is
raising to get evidence thrown out
continuing coverage of a hearing for
three members of a family charged
in the murder of a florida mother nicole
montavo disappeared last year after
dropping her son off at the home of her
estranged husband
christopher otero rivera he and his
father angel avera
are charged with murder his mother wanda
rivera
is charged with being an accessory the
defense says investigators initially
obtained a search warrant for a missing
persons case her dismembered remains
were found in rivera's property
and her car was found abandoned miles
down the road
we noticed the dome light inside the
vehicle was on
and the door was propped open it wasn't
closed entirely
as we were documenting the the position
of the car and how it was when we
located it
behind the trunk area right to the right
of the passenger tire there was a blue
latex glove
was that the only latex glove you found
no across the street
on the same side as big sky but there's
a
two-way road so one's an entrance and
one's next but they're side by side is
just a grass median
on the other side of the outgoing back
to 1i2
there is another latex blue colored
latex glove there as well
and it was directly the same
locations where the car was just on the
other side of the road
on cross the defense was quick to point
out what evidence
wasn't collected from the victim's car
well by our definition that would be an
abandoned vehicle there's no one around
it there's nobody near it
so that would classify as under ours as
an abandoned vehicle
are you the person that collected those
gloves yes and you submitted that to
evidence
correct you subsequently learned that
there was just no evidence on those
gloves that were tied to anyone in the
rivero family
i have no idea what the results were
those from those gloves okay fair enough
there's also tire marks there did you
see that
correct by any chance did you collect
those sidewalks
to try to compare to any vehicle at the
rivero family
no my role at that point because that
was the secondary club that we found
it was just a matching one to the same
one that we found directly behind the
car
okay go back
on redirect prosecutors asked why the
vehicle appeared
suspicious it wasn't directly
off of 192 there was some major distance
from like if you had an issue or stopped
you're normally going to stop a lot
closer to 192
in that area this is a little bit
further of a normal
normal distance you know off the roadway
did you all run the tag and confirm that
it belonged that the vehicle belonged to
nicole montalvo
correct when i was pulling in behind
with tim maroney he was reading me
when i walked into his car he just got
the return back from the tag he ran and
it was explained to me who it belonged
to
when we come back a mother missing then
found dead
why investigators knew right away to
look at her estranged husband
next
[Music]
back now to a florida hearing where the
defense for three suspects in a murder
case
want evidence tossed out a search for
nicole montavo began in october of 2019
when she failed to show up for work law
enforcement immediately turned their
sights
to her estranged husband christopher
ortera rivera
police thought she was kidnapped then
realized she had been murdered
but the defense says investigators were
deceitful when requesting their original
search warrant
they spread out through the home whether
they didn't take pictures
or open drawers they were not looking
for little pieces of evidence what they
were looking for was
was nicole montalvo at the residence was
her car at the
at the residence whether you want to
call it a warrior search or not
they were there and what they came out
of the resident
residence with was there was no signs of
the coal montable there was no
vehicle of nicole montalvo but they
don't include that in the affidavit
affidavit saint cloud police department
was there
what they got from saint cloud and
deputy decker was a conversation with mr
rivera who said
yeah hey nicole motavo was here she was
here on october 21st
she dropped off elijah rivera and then
she left
and a couple of hours later i get a text
message he shows up that text message
it's not what we learned later it's what
they knew at the time
prosecutors say investigators had plenty
of probable cause
and cited a history of violence from the
defendant towards the victim
the defendant christopher otero rivera
he was on community control for a 2018
incident that he had an active domestic
violence injunction against him for
trying to suffocate the victim
and trying to break her neck because she
was trying to take custody of
their son and because she had been quote
texting with a friend we also knew
that within a few months of her
disappearance
miss montalvo had begun dating a new
person
we also knew that miss montalbo's
relationship with the defendant
and the co-defendants had become
strained because of custody issues
the affidavit bears all these facts out
we also knew that the defendant and the
co-defendant
angel rivera had blackmailed the victim
threatening to release nude photos of
her over custody issues with the child
since this hearing was a motion from the
defense they got the final word
you can't break the law to enforce the
law the state is basically telling you
forget about the fourth amendment
we had someone missing they had a right
to go in there
no they didn't they have to establish
that they had probable cause
and they didn't do that um it sounds
more like where
uh the state is asking you uh
you know for some sympathy here like hey
listen we had this woman missing they
had
to do this is what they had to do no
they had to work within the
the confines of the law and they did it
right so let's break this down terry the
defense is getting creative in their
arguments
saying there was a lack of specificity
and a belief that a kidnapping actually
occurred
do those arguments persuade you in any
way you know brian
i was not persuaded but i think they
made a good
argument listen defense attorneys they
have an ethical duty
to provide effective representation to
the defendant at all times as you know
as a defense attorney
but the most damning evidence against
the defendant is
obviously the victim's body parts which
were found on the defendant's
property so the defense attorney is
going to have to argue as best they can
that this evidence should not be
admitted and they did argue
that there was no reason to actually
search the outside of the house and so i
think it's the best argument they could
have made
now gene prosecutors argued saying that
montavo's cell phone
was actually in the area the time of
disappearance and that's why they had to
write the right to search
who loses this argument and why
well here's the main argument of the
defense
it's a case called leon versus united
states
and what it says is that if the
officer who gets the affidavit for the
search warrant or gets a search warrant
uh in good faith relies on that search
warrant and later on a judge says
that the search warrant is not valid
then that search is
good so what we have here is when they
went to the magistrate judge or the
judge
with the affidavit were there misleading
pieces of information
the location of the car the location of
her cell phone
was there other significant omissions
of exculpatory information in the
affidavit
were they trying to mislead the
approving
judge with their affidavit if that
happened
then this search should be re oppressed
and what that defense attorney is we'll
see how that goes
genie yes i'm sorry thank you thanks for
that gene
i know we can go on for days but thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily see you next week
justin's in america
[Music]
you